i can see by that look on your face
you're wondering who i am after all let
me save you the trouble i'm donna
and i'm awesome
donna i need the oh also i didn't have a
chance to
marry me i took care of that too we've
been married for the last seven years
excellent
hi donna
harvey and i were just uh talking about
you no
you don't even know i was gonna say yes
i do
and how is that possible i read lips
i know body language and i talk to norma
i'm not some token
you win at a fair lewis you know i know
you're not you're not a token i'm a
human being and yes you are
i'm sorry i just
you know what that just made me feel
really
cheap
i'm just trying to tell you that you're
really good at what you do donna so i'm
gonna ask you it's like my soul
hurts
no
donna listen even if your soul hurts a
little bit i'm sorry
it's okay
it's gonna be fine
don't cry please don't cry donna oh [ __ ]
i think i owe you one for that that was
fun
wait a second
the time that you cried and then i let
your parents stay in my condo
yep how'd the negotiation go
you come out on top why don't you tell
me scotty was opposing counsel
because i didn't want you to have
performance anxiety
about the case she's tough you're
obvious your flies unzipped no it
doesn't but it was earlier today
you can do better ooh is that what
scotty said come on come on damn it
what are you doing uh nothing i'm just
sending some faxes
stand down
they're stuck donna what are you gonna
do
i'm the fax whisperer
okay that's ridiculous right i've tried
everything i've already done that and it
didn't
whatever
listen to me i want you goddamit and i
will throw that secretary right out the
window if i knew you were gonna be my
secretary but i have a reputation that i
value
and i'm not gonna be putting my
reputation on the line for something
that i do not believe in
american ballet theater
no
followed by a one-on-one dinner with
barishnikov
uh-huh
oh mommy
i
no no no no no no no
no
um
nope i'm sorry okay can't do it got it
okay mm-hmm huh do you understand why
it's very clear to you no no because do
you understand why i said no yes
i want to but i can
what
let go what let go
jessica would like to see you in our
office
oh that phony [ __ ] you are so beautiful
when you're forceful
you know you meant that as a compliment
but i don't appreciate limitations being
placed on my beauty
what was that
excuse me
please do me a favor and thank you all
in the same sentence you think i'm not
gonna notice that i don't have time for
this you got time you're gonna sit right
there while i figure out what the hell's
going on nothing's going on
dimple in your tie is too far to the
left that says that your mind is on
something else mr sherman's called 136
times you've never called him back which
means you're feeling guilty and you're
trying to compensate
i'm not trying i didn't say
overcompensate as long as we're clear
the only time i've ever seen you wear
lavender was when your brother was in
the hospital you're feeling protective
in an older brother manner whoa
either your mother somehow appeared in
your life or jessica found out about
mike
so you and mike i know it's a lot do you
want to talk about it of course i do
okay i think we should start with the
most important emotional question okay
[Music]
i'm actually getting worried for you you
don't have half of it
get out
and take your color-coded filing system
with you it's a system how do i i'm
trying to give the moment some dramatic
flair
jeez now we ruined that too
that's it that was worth making a whole
condition i've never fired anyone before
you know he's a floating temp right i
mean he'll be on somebody else's desk by
the end of lunch
does everyone have to reign on my parade
you're not monica oh no i'm rachel zane
how did you know that i'm donna i know
everything
sorry but apparently paul porter doesn't
believe in technology look i need the
employment survey yeah i'm working on it
it's not done
it's a survey of all 50 states you got
to get on this might could have done it
asleep i'm sorry i don't have a
photographic memory but my brain is
already too busy being awesome
you got overwhelmed with a wave of
emotion you didn't see coming you cried
and you let him stay no i saw the amount
of work i would have to go through to
replace him and decided against it did
you see the amount of work through a
pool of tears are you finished can i get
you anything tissue glass of water
tampon ooh rachel
what are you doing here you have access
to the partner's kitchen yeah i like to
keep my finger on the pulse
plus they don't have cheetos
actually i don't care about the pulse i
can promise you i'm better than good
steven hundley senior partner london
office
donna
just donna yeah it's like a name and a
title and one
you'll see
what happened do you want to talk about
it i have ice cream it's 8 a.m which is
why god made chunky monkey it has
chocolate and bananas bananas are part
of a healthy breakfast and who cares
about the bananas it has chocolate
okay you caught me i don't even eat the
bananas my old office
i wasn't kidding my idea
it took a while to feng shui the evil
out
look
donna i understand
you piece of [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
was that a good holy [ __ ] or a bad holy
[ __ ] harvey you just told me that you're
planning a coup give me a second to
figure that out not a coup
it's a move and when you're done with
your lecture no no lecture i just have
one question
do i get my own office
you've never made a copy in your life
before have you of course not i'm too
busy being a badass
i'm worrying about my hair so you're
gonna come out and say it say what
all those observations
you're into me
i'm not into you i'm donna what's that
supposed to mean it means i could do the
same thing with bertha that i did with
you all that means is that you're into
bertha too what if i am we can have a
threesome trust me
if you were ever lucky enough to have me
you wouldn't want to share
[Music]
new dress what can i say
it deserved me
what's the occasion does a girl need a
reason to look spectacular louis you're
almost up
oh christ you're sweating more than
nixon i've gone through four elizabethan
collars and a copyist okay just breathe
you're gonna be fine no i can't do it
lewis we are in the middle of the play
you'll have to ad-lib make something up
say [ __ ] went away say that he went
to israel oh my god
wow i don't even know what
you know what
i never thought you'd be so
weak okay why do you got to say
something hurtful right now hurt
turn that into rage why would i do it
you always turn hurt into rage you
idiotic piece of [ __ ] it is what you do
okay now i'm mad at you good
now imagine you're in court court how
it's too hard with the cause dude
diplomacy okay violent court god damn it
happy now no i'm not happy you idiot now
you're in court and you're enraged and
you are fit to kill
now do you see that audience out
there that's your jury you're a bunch of
morons yeah they're beneath you aren't
they they're beneath everybody what else
they're a bunch of civil servants who
can't keep up with what i'm saying you
have absolutely total contempt for them
don't you i want to rip out their stupid
brains from their stupid head exactly
now get out there and make your case
unless of course you're a [ __ ] and you
were meant to play plaque your whole
life 3 000
seconds
what do you mean it's a no i mean it's a
cute joke but i'm not interested in
pursuing it as a business opportunity i
don't understand i thought you liked the
idea i did but that was before i
realized that it was nothing but
quippy lines and sassy remarks but
that's who you are no benjamin
that's part of who i am and it's the
only part you've ever seen but that's
because we don't really know each other
but if we did you'd know that what
really makes me special is my intuition
and my empathy
my heart
everybody
[Music]
is